in March 1845
the United States acquired a new
President James K pulk a forceful
aggressive political outsider intent on
strengthening his country and asserting
its preeminence in front of other world
powers especially Mexico and Great
Britain within a year of his
inauguration he had declared full-scale
war on Mexico because of squabbles over
the Texan border and was soon rattling
his saber at Britain over the ownership
of Oregon to complete the picture Polk
was a vigorous defender of slavery who
dismissed the arguments of abolitionists
as naive and sentimental Hulk was a
popular president admired by many for
his gung-ho manner but a sizable
minority of the citizenry disliked him
intensely one especially committed
opponent was a writer from Massachusetts
called Henry David Thoreau Thoreau is
now a canonical American literary figure
studied in every high school for his
lyrical masterpiece Walden but there is
another more political side to Thoreau
now usually airbrushed out of his story
which came to the fore in relation to
the president Thoreau quickly realized
that he was opposed to everything Polk
stood for he hated what became the
mexican-american war instinctively
siding with the losing Mexican side he
was weary of pulk squabbles with Britain
and was appalled by the administration's
policy of hunting down and returning
runaway slaves to their masters in the
south sorrows anger against his
president found its impassioned
expression in an essay he published in
18-49 now known as civil disobedience at
the heart of the essay is the question
of what an honest citizen should do
about a president he or she
wholeheartedly opposes the prevailing
view was it because Polk had won a
majority those who were against him
should now fall silent it should it was
often said be the duty of a good citizen
to fold away their objections and just
respect the will of the majority but
this was precisely the point the ROE
wish to probe and upturn he suggested
that
Patriots were not those who blindly
followed their administration they were
those who followed their own consciences
and in particular the principles of
Reason Thoreau wish to redistribute
prestige away from blinkered obedience
towards independent thought
what marked out a noble citizen of the
Republic a real American was not in
Pharaoh's view that they respectfully
shut up but that they thought for
themselves every day of an
administration's life on the basis of
justice kind of independent thinking
Thoreau signaled a radical opposition to
pols term he denounced the
mexican-american war the repatriation of
slaves and the outlook of the government
more generally and so as to underline
his opposition Thoreau held back payment
of his taxes in July 1846 he walked into
Concord Massachusetts to get his shoes
repaired and was promptly arrested and
thrown into the town's Jail
Thoreau saw nothing undignified about
spending some time behind bars as he
wrote under a government which imprisons
any unjustly the true place for a just
man is a prison all machines have their
friction Thoreau admitted but when
injustice is too great you should let
your life be a counter friction to stop
the machine Thoreau didn't advocate the
non-payment of taxes as a rule and in
fact a well-meaning armed soon paid his
bill the non-payment was just one
example of the many nonviolent ways that
a democratically elected government
could and should be resisted whenever
its actions veer into aggression or
unreason an election may settle who the
president might be but it doesn't
determine but everything the president
does is right or that one should simply
do nothing until the next election above
all sorrow hated political passivity
sarcastically he wrote there are
thousands who are in opinion opposed to
slavery and to the wall who yet in
effect do nothing to put an end to them
who esteeming themselves children of
Washington and Franklin sit down with a
hand in their pocket and say that they
know not what to do and do nothing this
would not be thorough
how does it become a man to behave
towards this American government today I
answer that he cannot without disgrace
be associated with it the row argued
that the citizens must never just resign
his conscience to the legislation and
put himself at the service of some
unscrupulous man in power
sirot mocked that most legislators
politicians lawyers ministers and office
holders are as likely to serve the devil
without intending it as God the RO would
not be such a servant this most American
of writers knew exactly whom it was
right for him to serve his own mind and
conscience
you